avec les poissons et crustacés une fois
la chaire retirer les carcasses ont
encore beaucoup à offrir
en deux temps trois mouvements on peut
spar savoureux refus mais avaient quand
on achète peuple poisson entier
le poissonnier va faire son travail va
vous levez les beaux filets et on garde
les arrêtant demande de mettre les
arrête à pas et on va pouvoir faire le
fumer grâce aux lots carcasses de
poisson est-ce que vous gardez tête et
que aussi je garde tout ce qu'on va
enlever c'est uniquement les branchies
savez le système respiratoire
ce qui est très important c'est le faire
dégorger dans l'eau donc un bain d'eau
glacée au frigo une nuit puis on change
le lendemain en fait le but c'est
d'enlever un maximum de 100 dans un
contenu dans la colonne vertébrale et
dans les arrête
moi j'aime les poissons blancs c'est
beaucoup plus délicat c'est sûr qu'on
peut utiliser les carcasses de saumons
qui est beaucoup plus gras donc on aura
des fumées beaucoup plus gras et
beaucoup moins agréable où on prépare
une garniture aromatique avec de
l'oignon et du sénat ont fait suit
quelques minutes dans de l'huile ou du
bar puis on y ajoute les morceaux de
carcasses
on veut pas rôtir les légumes fumée à
claire et donc je vous dirai peut-être
1 5-10 minutes tranquillement moyen fort
on veut juste cuir et les carcasses sans
les brûler ça va concentrer nos saveurs
puis à partir de là on va il est déposé
le bouquet garni et puis on va mouiller
à l'eau alors encore une fois quand vous
mouiller on veut pas faire un aquarium
contrairement un fond de veau par
exemple qui va cuire pendant 24 à 48
heures le fumer sera prêt très
rapidement le but c'est de monter le
fumé à ébullition de réduire l'intensité
du feu et puis de peu de cuir ça à
frémissement pendant 20 minutes ce qui
est super important
en montant le fumé à ébullition c'est
justement qu'ils servent à coaguler
toutes les protéines du poisson et c'est
ce qui remonte à la surface
le sang etc et donc ça c'est très
important de l'écumé bcm porté leur
enlever ces impuretés là pour avoir
un fumée très clair après vingt minutes
de frémissement il ne reste plus qu'à de
filtrer et enfin on pourra profiter de
ce concentré de saveurs voilà la base le
fut mais ça va servir à accueillir nos
poissons donc on va cuire nos poissons
dans dans son bouillon danser dans sa
saveur on va ça va c'est la base de
toute les sauces également en cuisine
donc si on a un bon fumée un bon un bon
fond on aura des bonnes sauces on peut
faire le même exercice avec des
carcasses de crustacés c'est bientôt la
saison de l'eau marron né dedans
donc quand vous faites vos souper homard
on garde toutes les carcasses puis là on
va pouvoir faire des ponts de crustacés
également et s'est mise à part le homard
à ce que je préfère la même chose pour
les crabes les crevettes qui donne
absolument des très bons font un très
bon fumée oui effectivement
le but c'est d'avoir un fonds qui va
être le plus parfumé possible
au départ on va faire caraméliser les
carcasses en commençant par celles qui
sont crus puis on ajoute nos légumes qui
forment la garniture aromatique oignons
poireaux céleri carotte et ail et au
bouquet garni
on note une belle caramélisation on va
ajouter un peu de tomates pour donner un
peu d'eux du corps puis un peu de
couleurs rayonnantes à la pâte de tomate
on trouvera concerne je des glaces avec
un peu de vin blanc auquel on se permet
tout jargon on avait une réserve pour le
fumet de passe mal
on peut flamber au cognac aussi dans les
poutres eh bien en v'là joannon on a
mouillé juste hauteur on ne fait pas un
aquarium et puis là j'aime ça il met un
peu l'anis étoilé
ça ramène un petit goût à nice et un peu
de poivre
parce que rien comme ça comme ça voilà
donc et puis ça on le porte à ébullition
encore une fois on va venir l'écumé
comme on a fait avec notre fumet de
poisson et on va le cuire à frémissement
pendant une heure par la suite on va
retirer les gros morceaux de carcasses
et tout filtrer pour ne garder que le
liquide qui nous servira pour des sauces
ou même des souris ces manifs et non
seulement ça sent divinement bon mais
c'est de toute beauté
il ya beaucoup de choses là dedans vous
avez ajouté à la main excessivement on a
utilisé tout le poisson on a eu aucune
perte là dedans on a utilisé tous que le
poisson pouvait nous offrons
[Musique]